hey
you
let's play for a moment
[Music]
what is the nature
of our reality
what's the nature
of consciousness
awareness the very
knowingness
of our existence
our being
how profound is it how much
awe
for just this experience
happening right now
the very now
this simply
[Music]
awaken to the profundity
of simply this
now
every single heartbeat
is so profound
[Music]
every time that we look
into the pupils
of someone else's eyes
[Music]
we see god
and we wake up
and we recognize that we
are it
we are god we
are source we
are infinity
expressing itself
each of us a creative unique
[Music]
expression
and then we live
from that knowing
that knowing becomes home
we are infinite we are
eternal our awareness
our consciousness is
being colored by experience
and once we have that
knowingness of ourselves
as that being
infinitely colored
[Music]
we become more and more
awake we pierce the veil
more and more we self-realize
more and more we feel the child-like
laughter of the infinite we
feel the well of honey
underneath the rock the rock
of the separate entity of egoic
consciousness that
does not serve us it does not serve
humanity shed your onion layers
of identity
release the clenched fist
of the contracted ego and dissolve
the sugar cube of that contraction
in the hot tea of infinity
you are that
we are that
share that knowing
[Music]
share it with your mom
your dad your family your kids
share it with your closest
friends share it with your co-workers
share it with people online
make that home that
is home that is who we are
and we are all walking
each other home
i love you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you